GROW.
>>> SPANISH AUTHORITIES ARE
WARNING RESIDENTS ON THE CANARY
ISLAND OF LA PALMA TO TAKE
PRECAUTIONS AS VOLCANIC ACTIVITY
RESUMES.
LAVA HAS BEEN SPEWING OUT OF THE
VOLCANO FOR NINE DAYS, FORCING
ABOUT 6,000 PEOPLE TO EVACUATE.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS VIDEO OF A
CHURCH COLLAPSE JUST HOURS AGO.
IT CAUSED IT TO CRUMBLE TO THE
GROUND.
HUNDREDS OF HOMES AND BUSINESSES
HAVE BEEN DESTROYED SINCE THE
VOLCANO ERUPTED.
WE'RE JOINED FROM THE SPANISH
CAPITAL OF MADRID.
DRAMATIC SCENES WE'RE WITNESSING
AT THE MOMENT.
HOW SERIOUS IS THE SITUATION NOW
THAT THOUSAND OF PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN EVACUATED?
DO WE HAVE ANY SENSE OF WHEN
THIS IS GOING TO END?
>> ELENI, EXPERTS SAY THIS COULD
GO ON FOR A COUPLE OF MONTHS, SO
WE'RE IN THE EARLY DAYS
ACCORDING TO VOLCANO EXPERTS,
AND ALL EYES ARE ON THE EDGE
TOWARD THE ATLANTIC OCEAN ON THE
EAST SIDE OF THE ISLAND.
AS THE DAY STARTED, THE LAVA
FLOWED ABOUT ONE MILE.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS IT COULD
REACH THE SEA SOON.
AND THE AUTHORITIES KNOW THAT
THAT WILL CAUSE FURTHER PROBLEMS
BECAUSE ONCE THIS RED-HOT LAVA
HITS THE OCEAN, THERE WILL BE
TOXIC GASES COMING UP.
THIS WAS EXPECTED AS EARLY AS
LAST WEEK.
THE LAVA HAS BEEN FLOWING FASTER
AND IT COOLS WITH THE SURFACE
AND THERE'S MORE LAVA.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR DAYS, BUT
NOW THEY THEY DON'T WANT SHIPS
COMING IN.
THE TOXIC FUMES COULD BE FATAL.
THEY'RE ALL SET FOR THAT.
NOW, THE NUMBER OF HOMES ARE IN
THE HUNDREDS LIKE THAT CHURCH
THAT YOU JUST SHOWED, ALSO
BANANA PLANTATIONS THAT PROVIDES
BANANAS TO THE REST OF EUROPE.
IT'S COMING ON HIGH TOURISM
SEASON.
SO IT'S A DRAMATIC MOMENT FOR
THE ERUPTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
GOING ON.
THERE WAS A SLIGHT PAUSE FOR A
COUPLE OF HOURS THIS DAY WHERE
AUTHORITIES AND VOLCANO EXPERT
SASD THERE WAS ALMOST NO
ACTIVITY, NO ASH COMING OUT, AND
THEN THAT RESUMED.
THE LAVA FLOW, WHICH IS COMING
OUT AND PILING ON TOP, ONE LAVA
FLOW THAT GETS CAUGHT BY ANOTHER
ONE AS THERE'S A NEW ERUPTION
HEADING DOWN RELENTLESSLY TOWARD
SEA IN SOME PLACES STANDS 38
FEET TALL.
SO IT'S A MASSIVE ISSUE.
IT'S CUTTING OFF HIGHWAYS, AND
THE 6,000 PEOPLE AUTHORITIES SAY
ARE SAFE, BEING TAKEN CARE OF,
THEY'RE STAYING WITH FRIENDS OR
FAMILY IN THEIR HOMES.
THE GOOD NEWS, AUTHORITIES SAY,
IS THERE ARE NO ROSHTS OF